Just before we get started,
some of you might know that I have another channel called mega projects,
which is all about mega projects. If you don't know about that,
please do subscribe to it. Well, by popular demands,
I wanted to cover some things on that channel. The one quite mega enough for it.
So I presented to you a brand new channel side projects,
cover stuff like secrets, Soviet space weapons, world war two is greatest liens.
History is the lost treasures and the movements of London bridge from London to
a random town in America. Stuff likes that new videos every week.
So if you were thinking, boy, Simon doesn't make enough content for me. Well,
good news for you subscribed to that channel.
There is a link below and let's get into it.
North Korea is a nation that list its size and kinds of reaction from the worlds
and not always the positive GYNs the country. We know these days,
at least from the global news perspective is one that is fraught with
controversy is dictatorship of the highest order.
This of course ignores the Marianne.
It's a beautiful things that North Korea has to offer through its culture, food,
music, and social graces. And as the constant spectra of the current leader,
Kim Jong-un stirring the pot doesn't help matters. His father,
Kim Jong-il was also an expert to keeping world leaders on their toes.
But before all of that, there was the founder of North Korea,
Kim Il-sung from the ashes of world war two.
He founded the country in 1948 with the help of the Soviet union during his
reign, the country of North Korea prospered. And to this day,
the shadow of Kim Il-sung looms large over the nation.
Long after his death occurred in 1994,
the Coulter personality that was propagated around him is still strong.
And he is known as the eternal president of the Republic.
Entire new calendars were created based around when he was sent from
heaven. Today,
we will discuss the legacy of the man who birthed the nation of North Korea.
Kim Il-sung
Wilson was born Kim song Jew on April the 15th, 1912, the same day,
the Titanic tragic leap plunged into the depths of the Atlantic ocean though.
His exact place of birth has been under scrutiny.
We know that he was raised somewhere near the current capital of present day,
North Korea, Pyongyang. His parents lived a modest life while raising,
given his two brothers and tried to introduce religion into their lives with
several of his family members being involved in the Presbyterian, faith,
the faith of the family, wasn't just relegated to the church.
They also held the fervent belief that the Japanese occupation of Korea was
wrong and unjust.
Japan had been taking over the Korean peninsula two years before Kim was born
and his family outwardly and publicly protested.
The act Japan's response to the Korean uprising was Swift and measured with over
50,000 arrests of Korean citizens in Kim's birth year,
Japan effectively ruled the country from 1910 until the end of world war II in
1945. And countless families were displaced.
Kim and his family were included in this displacement and Kim himself would not
return to his home country until Japan surrendered.
At the conclusion of the war Kim's father was a physician, a teacher,
and held a certain power over the young boy showing him just how badly
imperialists Japan needed to be brought down in his autobiography.
Kim recalled being five years old, playing on a swing with his mother,
cradling him and already steadfast and as well to defeat the evil forces of
Japan. When he was six, he was already joining ranks of protesters in the March.
The first two movements,
one of the largest public protests in Korea against their occupied Japan,
absolutely annihilated the rebellion,
but can at least according to his own accounts was right there in the middle of
the fray later recalling. When the adults cheered for independence,
I joined them. The enemy used swords and guns.
Indiscriminantly against the masses.
This was the day I witnessed Korean blood being spilled for the first time.
My young heart burned with indignation.
Since there isn't much in the way of concrete details of this part of Kimmel
Il-sung childhood, much of what we think we know is from his autobiography,
which she certainly embellished.
He spun tales of being a young boy in teen and laying spike strips across the
road to take out Japanese police vehicles.
But the crystallization of his suppose,
a destiny to take his country back seems to have happened at age 14 when his
father passed away while the family was an exile in Manchuria, before he died,
he told his eager son,
you must not forget that you belong to the country and the people you must win
back your country at all costs.
Even if your bones are broken and your bodies are torn apart,
Kim Wilson was still just an awkward teenager,
but his upcoming school studies and UN middle school and Manchuria would prepare
him with the kind of revolutionary thought that would guide him through his
formative years until then he founded the down with imperialism union,
which is what exactly what it sounds like.
He also attended the was soon military Academy,
but was quickly unimpressed by their methods.
Something you don't usually expect from a 14 year old boy,
he lasted one year at the Academy in total. Why don't you?
And middle-school Kim began to lean towards communist ideals rejecting the more
traditional feudal views held by the older folks and adopting a more
self-reliant outlook.
He took parts in forming an underground Marxist group at the age of 17 and acts
that ends in a short stint in jail.
When the police found out and an abrupt end to his education,
these small acts of aggression,
which is preparing him to formally join the communist party in China in 1931,
Resentment towards the Japanese whom he blamed for being exiled from his own
country of Korea.
Kim jumped at the chance to help out the communist party in a more official
capacity after spending time scrapping with several ragtag guerrilla groups in
China, when he called Manchuria his temporary home,
the Japanese hadn't bothered the region much until 1930,
when several violent skirmishes arose,
which made it clear that the conflict was impending.
Kim couldn't escape the Japanese, no matter where he turns,
he saw his chance to step up and warns that a plan Japanese occupation of
Manchuria was coming and a defining speech to the communist league in May, 1931,
Kim galvanized all anti-Japanese allies at his disposal,
detailed why previous uprisings had failed and basically predicted to the crowd
exactly what would happen four months later,
soon after the Japanese government used a minor attack on their railroads in
Manchuria to send forces in and invade and install their own government.
Kim was incensed. He joined yet another coalition,
the Northeast anti Japanese United army.
He took up arms and was given control of troops with the backing of the
communist party of China. Kim led several hundred men. His battle ends.
It ends the praise and tutelage of military higher ups with close ties to
Chinese leader, Mao Zedong himself.
This was the time Ken began to make himself larger than life and built his own
legend. As he saw fit, he changed his name officially to Kim Il-sung,
which translates to Kim, become the son,
not exactly a law humble way to introduce yourself to the world.
He became as brash as his name and took control of the sixth division of the
United army. One bold attack on a Japanese downtown in June,
1937 was particularly notable because it involved him and his troops capturing a
city, Justin scientist's home country of Korea. It was a symbolic victory.
One that laid bare his plans for his future and for the Korean people,
he was coming home one way or another.
The Japanese had begun taking notice of the young military leader too.
They had wanted posters for his capture, labeling him for Tanya.
He was actively hunted by special Japanese units during 1940 that year saw the
world already embroiled in the second world war.
So battle lines were already being drawn all the way around the globe.
One place where Kim's efforts were appreciated was the Soviet union.
And that country offered him a sort of refuge.
When Japanese forces went off to him and allowed his regimen to be trained by
Soviet forces and to even join the Soviet red army as a major and fought with
them for the rest of the war. Kim was also beginning to grow his family.
It was these years. So him and his wife, Kim Jong soak having three children,
one of whom was Kim Jong IL,
who would go on to start his own special brand of trouble. A little later,
I have now spent the majority of his grown life fighting outside forces to be
able to simply go back home.
When the Soviet union probably declared war on Japan in 1945 and started their
approach into the Korean city of Pyongyang.
Kevin was afforded the chance to set foot back into his birth nation Soviet
leader. Joseph Stalin instructed as leaders to occupy career rooms wanted
recommendations on who could help install the temporary communist government.
That Kim was the perfect candidate.
After 26 years of being removed from his Homeland.
Kim soon was elected the chairman of the North Korean communist party in
December, 1945. That doesn't mean he was ready from day one, strangely enough.
He had spent little time in his own country.
So he didn't even know that much of the Korean language.
You had to be coached for his own inaugural speech just days before it took
place. Kim effectively ran the Northern part of Korea.
As far as administrative rank goes, though,
he still answered directly to the Soviets occupying his country,
which meant that even though he was finally home,
he was still under someone else's finger for the time being can also did launch
the Korean people's army offshoot of the communist party and used his previous
military and contacts for me, a formidable army and air force. Again,
using that handy Soviet training and equipment.
The strife between the North and South parts of Korea started not long after
world war two,
when the U S and Russia decided to cut the country in half the Soviets
controlled the Northern regions and the Americans,
the South and the ensuing cold war did nothing but add more tension within the
Korean peninsula.
The Soviet tells elections in 1948 for a true leader of the newly named
democratic people's Republic of Korea, or as you know it, North Korea with Kim,
Il-sung running the title of premiere,
the South named simply Republic of Korea that their own leader and declared
their own state. It give them quickly consolidated power,
merging the communist party with other affiliations and organizations and
morphing into something that resembled a bit more of a dictatorship.
The power of Kim as an individual was quickly increasing,
and he was already making bold moves in the North.
He had statutes created and distributed around the country and began doubling
himself great leader. The cult of personality was already on display.
His policies were as audacious as his view of himself.
He proclaims that half of all farmable lands should be redistributed in order
for enough food to be produced for his people.
It also gave him the added pleasure of taking back lands that were still held by
many Japanese property.
Owners can also introduce to Countrywide standard eight hour Workday,
which was more like an overall guide as to how people should spend that day.
Kimberly was in eight hours, work, eight hours rest and data was studied,
can also introduce healthcare for all.
And it was one of the best systems in all of Asia for quite some time for Ken
may well-educated well arrested where I could put less of a burden on the
healthcare system. More health equals.
Well production.
The border between.
North and South Korea was sat around 1948 at the 38th parallel though.
Neither country openly admitted that they were split at all.
Obviously the Soviets who helps run the North and the Americans who occupied the
South disagreed criminal sewing had no small part in deciding that reclaiming
all of Korea was something that needed to be done.
Starlin was armed with intelligence that the U S wouldn't intervene if such an
invasion occurred.
And Kim was made bolder by the fact that China would also assist.
And so in 1950, Kim's North Korean army headed South and quickly took Seoul.
The capital of South Korea.
The South Saami were already on their heels and Kim's army began occupying most
of their land,
but that was when Stalin's information or lack thereof as soon proved false.
As the United States have blown with the United nations,
absolutely began to intervene.
Then U S president Truman received word almost instantly of the North Koreans
transgression,
and even compared the act stupidness sweep across Europe in the 1930s,
then got the ball rolling for the Americans,
do throw their hat into the war ringings for the next three years,
Kim and his country teat,
dotted back and forth between advancing in the conflict and subsequently having
to retreat Kevin's prions taking of the city of Seoul was thoughted several
times the help from Chinese forces bailed them out more than once,
but even still Kim's capital of Pyongyang was overrun by United nations
armies buying September, 1950.
You have to flee to the Northern reaches of his own country in a kind of
metaphor for his entire life. China again, came to the rescue.
The next year in Pyongyang was restored to team. North Korea can,
would face these kinds of shallow victories and defeats for the next two years
until the war ended in 1953 at a cost of over two and a half million lives.
Kim was resentful of the Chinese getting all the glory in the war while the
North Korean armies were relegated to the sidelines for a lot of the skirmishes.
Kim also saw his grand prospect of reuniting.
The entire Korean peninsula is one country slipping through his fingers,
and increasingly forced to have a truce forms later in the war that didn't stop
him from claiming victory immediately after the war ended. However,
and it didn't stop his people and country folk from holding that legend in there.
[Inaudible].
Displays Kim Il-sung touting.
The ends of the Korean war is a victory for the North is off of the country was
in tatters. Sure. He was still in power as the leader of North Korea,
but it was economy and people were decimated.
So while he did what he was good at, he consolidated power.
He had the country take over industry completely with an especially heavy focus
on arms production and military expansion.
And it worked for a time as the 1950s,
continued as country was actually doing better in many ways than South Korea,
where the U S still remained and whose economy was incredibly unstable,
can married for the second time. In 1952 to Kim song,
a whom many thought that Kim Il-sung had been seeing secretly before his first
wife even passed away with her.
He has two more sons and a daughter in a different approach than he usually
allowed.
Kim gave his wife a considerable amount of power in North Korean politics.
Kim himself remains a bastion of communism,
touting its benefits on the international stage.
He sided with Chinese communist leader mountain and began reading his own
country of those who did not follow his beliefs.
Allies quickly became enemies pack on young was a close confidant of Kim's
during the Korean war and was high in the ranks of the Korean worker's party,
the dominant political party in North Korea.
He Rose to the title of foreign minister, which he held from 1948 to 1953.
Once the war was over and Soviet leader,
Joseph Stalin died relationship soured between Ken and PAC Kim sought to
get rid of those who still had allegiances to the Soviet union and China and
make the regime has entirely allegations of PAC spying for the United States
against North Korea were fabricated. And finally in 1955,
Kim had him executed against the Soviets wishes, the path to Kim,
trying to establish his own independence,
upset the Soviets and the Chinese Kim Olson was brought to Moscow for six weeks
in the summer of 1956 to receive a stern warning regarding him falling out of
line with the Soviets ideas for how North Korea should be run during that time,
Korean communist groups and pro Soviet factions in North Korea fans,
how to confront him upon his return.
They obviously had to attack him during his next big assembly speech during
which they brought up his methods of perjuring high ranking officials and
executing them,
causing starvation and famine among these people by hyper-focusing on
industrialization.
And for trying to consolidate too much power in his own hands.
It was called the August faction and obvious attempt to overthrow chem and it
failed.
He began brutally going after all pro Chinese and pro-Soviet people and any kind
of power in this country,
they began to flee back to their respective countries rather than be rounded up
in prison or executed. There was almost no one left to question again,
then it's by 1958,
North Korea was fully independent with no debts left to China or the Soviet
union. Kim started to unfurl his newfound power in astounding ways.
He initiated a massive system in which its citizens were classified.
It was called the song Bon cost system,
and it categorized a person and do three different groups,
which were core wavering and hostile.
Much of this information was derived from that person's personal history and
which group they fit into directly impacted what kind of social benefits they
would receive. This included where they would be allowed to own a home,
which schools they could attend and even how much food they would be allotted.
If a poor unfortunate soul happened to be included in the hostile class,
they would be ostracized.
And often forcibly moved to remote areas of the country or hostile.
Wouldn't be alone in this trip though.
Often their entire families would be sent packing with them regardless of their
political affiliations or past histories.
There were untold numbers of forced labor camps called Kwan.
Liso where political prisoners and other national dissenters were often in turn
for their entire lives.
Suffice it to say the conditions in these camps were horns with countless tales
of sexual abuse, torture and starvation. Kim Il-sung banished,
all sorts of real and perceived enemies to a fate,
almost worse than death and wielded an immense power that only enhanced his
cult of personality.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] made it a point to stay close with other communist countries like
Romania in East Germany. And so,
although he had some frayed relations with the Soviet union,
he began to rebuild trust with them.
As Israel extended into the 1960s and seventies,
the sixties saw him and his North Vietnamese leader,
hoochie men's developer mutual respect for each other.
Kim saw how hokey men tried to bring North and South Vietnam together.
And it echoed the way Kim, it attempted to do the same thing with his country.
The ensuing war in Vietnam would bring the two men even closer in 1965 can
begin sending military and financial assets to North Vietnam.
His fighting began to take over the country.
Kim saw potential in the communist leader who she men and each years,
or millions more in financial backing for North Vietnam, as well as uniforms,
training, and military,
as support Kim told his brief pilots to fight in the war as if the Vietnamese
sky with our own. And to show you this,
it wasn't just offering help to military personnel.
North Vietnamese students were given free education in North Korea.
Kim was trying to build a long-term relationship, but it was fleeting.
Once North Vietnam started to look for an end to the walk in the Gans day issue.
The United States was now completely wrapped up in Vietnam's warrant.
Kim wanted to make sure they stayed that the more attention they gave Vietnam,
the less North Korea received.
It was an extra slap in the face when the war ended in 1975 and North and South
Vietnam actually unified where the careers had failed to do so.
The rest of the 1970s Sorkin began to look to its success. Though.
We oversaw a new constitution drafted for North Korea in 1972,
and it changed his title from premier to presidents.
He started to realize he was approaching the end of his reign.
North Korea was struggling economically.
While South Korea was boosted by American money and was prospering North Korea.
His practice of [inaudible], which was a method of extreme self-reliance.
It was coming back to bite them as they deliberately alienated themselves from
the rest of the world.
Kim also began to develop a launch tumor on the back of his neck,
something he was self-conscious about to the point of making photographers,
shoot him from his more flattering site.
The time had come to think about the future of his country.
And so at an assembly in 1980, he named his son, Kim Jong-il as successor.
Once he was gone, it wasn't exactly setting his son up for success. However,
former allies weren't interested in helping North Korea, his economy,
China had reformed the points where North Korea didn't have anything to offer
them financially. It also befriended South Korea.
The Soviet union would teach her and then completely implode and revolution
during the late eighties and early nineties,
North Korea was an Island of its own making Kim Il-sung seem to tire of
being on that Island at some point during the 1990s. However,
when North Korea began to embark on their own nuclear program,
former us president, Jimmy Carter,
traveled to North Korea to try and talk him down from such a hostile endeavor.
Amazingly Kim agreed to put a stop to the program and his new openness to
negotiation seemed to be a step in the right direction to getting North Korea,
to be a part of the world's neighborhood,
but it wouldn't lost on July the eighth, 1994,
Kim suffered a heart attack at his home in Pyongyang.
Kim Jong-il tried to summon the best doctors North Korea had to his father's
side, but it was for naught and Kimmel's son passed away at the age of 82,
a 10 day mourning period was instituted around the country and his body was
housed in a public mausoleum where it can be viewed to this very day,
give all some left behind a troubled nation.
One that would become further isolated and aggressive towards the world.
Under his son's rule.
His image is still prominent in the country presence at every train station and
airport and dotting the landscape in the form of countless statues.
His birthday is still a public holiday while the man who was forced from his
birth home and fought tirelessly to get back there built a troubling legacy.
The fact remains that he directly affected many of the 20th centuries biggest
events, and that's no small feat. So really hope you found that video.
Interesting. If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos, just like this several times a week,
and as always, thank you for.